my mustache grew through when i was
about 14
and then the rest of my beard eventually
followed about five years later
[Music]
one of the puzzles of human evolution is
why men and some populations have kept
their facial hair
when we've lost the hair and the rest of
our bodies now normally when we're
trying to explain a trait that doesn't
have any clear survival benefit we ask
whether it can help attract a mate
but actually beards don't seem to be
important to women in general
what we do find is that beards can help
men look more dominant
and that suggests it ties into male male
competition my beard makes me feel
more masculine and it makes me want to
take on the world
and people respond to me in a very very
positive manner when i have a beard
i'm not sure it makes me feel more of a
man makes me feel more like me
it helped me feel i'll say older or
more closer to my age because i look
quite young and i think it helped me
to look more of a mature adult a light
beard can exaggerate and emphasize the
jawline which is a key feature of male
facial masculinity so a babyface man can
make himself look older and more
dominant by growing a beard
but there's evidence that a man with a
highly masculinized dominant looking
bone structure
can actually soften that and look more
caring by growing a fuller beard
the recent resurgence in victorian
aesthetics is particularly interesting
because it's been argued the victorians
were reacting to earlier fashions in the
industrial revolution
by asserting a very strong natural form
of masculinity
including full beards as a sign of
figure and strength i like my beard
because it's smart
it's fashionable and it's trendy of
course beards can be subject to fashion
just like any fashion the scope for
individual self-expression
so keeping your beard well groomed and
glossy may be styled in a particular way
just like polishing your shoes or
choosing particular clothes
can say something about who you are and
what you want others to see
not so much like i wanted to go on my
bed it was mainly me being
lazy i just wake up kind of wash it with
a final and that's about it
i've been wanting to grow a beard for a
very long time and
it complements my face facial and head
hair can be used to mark out groups
within a particular population
now different traditions had different
specific rules
but what they all did was use hair as a
way to mark themselves out as distinct
and different
now today people can still use their
hair as a way of demonstrating their
piety each tradition
will have their own narrative about why
keeping or shaving their hair is
important but what they all have in
common
is the use of hair to make a visible
statement about group identity
about who they are and who they aren't i
went to hajj and i came back and for
spiritual reasons well i decided to keep
the beard
as the beard gets whiter you get more
wiser it's the same you
get more wisdom i like the length and
the color
and the way waves in the wind people
look to complement my beard as well so
i'm really happy with it costly
signaling theory is the principle that
anything in nature which requires the
investment of time or energy can be used
to indicate an underlying strength
now we can see this play out on the
social level as well growing a long
beard takes a considerable amount of
time
maintaining a beard requires time and
effort and that time spent can be used
as a visible symbol of commitment
to the group or to the ideology i don't
do a great deal of maintenance on my
beard i often mean to but because
sometimes i garden
i forget and come home with a bird stuck
in it
it almost changes my character i feel
like i i'm someone different
i feel more of a man i feel older it
ages me
but i can at least pretend i'm wiser
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video